[Musique]
à moins de 30 jours du premier tour de
la présidentielle en france nous
poursuivons notre réflexion sur ce
moment politique et démocratique avec
vous aujourd'hui martial foucault
bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes directeur du cevipof le centre
d'étude de la vie politique française
drôle de campagne que celle que nous
vivons martial foucault et que vous
observez j'imagine comme d'autres est
l'éclatement de la guerre en ukraine a
écrasé un débat politique qu'on nous
promettait intense depuis deux mois la
menace du retour de la guerre en europe
de l'ouest a rendu quasiment tout autre
sujet inaudible est ce que vous diriez
que ça fait de cette campagne si la plus
singulière de l'histoire de la vème
république
oui probablement sur un ton très très
long mais souvenons nous en 2017 on
avait déjà utilisé beaucoup de
qualificatifs pour décrire cette
campagne totalement historique inédite
disruptive donc cette fois-ci vous avez
raison de dire que un fait d'une telle
ampleur et d'une telle importance et qui
ne s'est jamais produit sous là sous la
vème république rend la campagne à la
fois très compliqué pour les candidats
eux mêmes très difficile pour les
français de dépasser cette actualité
extrêmement préoccupante et dans le même
temps je dirais que tout cela il y à un
moment très précis c'est à la fois
l'entrée en campagne d'emmanuel macron
déclenchement de cette guerre en ukraine
et ça donne le sentiment qu'on a tout
oublié cette pré campagne où il y avait
déjà eu comme des affrontements mais la
première conséquence est vraiment la
plus importante et il vous l'avez dit
c'est que ça écrase à tel point tous les
autres sujets et qui provoque une une
grande question quand les français quand
les candidats pourront débattre des
sujets domestiques est-ce que c'est
reporté pour les élections législatives
ou bien est ce que ce sera totalement
occulté rendant ce quinquennat prochain
extrêmement difficile en termes 2g dire
de responsabilité politique d'un
candidat ou d'une candidate élue
vis-à-vis des électeurs voilà privé les
français
contraints et forcés peut-être un de ce
moment démocratique important ça pose
effectivement plusieurs risques est ce
que nos campagnes campagne en sourdine
ça veut peut se muer en non mobilisation
avec l'inconnu pour le coup que ça fait
peser sur le scrutin oui alors c'est
vrai qu'on dit depuis plusieurs semaines
que cette campagne respect des français
qui est une forme de de désintérêt ou
une mise à distance de l'élection
présidentielle moi je remarque dans les
différentes enquêtes que nous menons que
en fait on assiste à un changement dans
le rapport des français à la politique
ce temps très très longues pendant des
semaines et des semaines on parle on
discute on délibère de politique est
presque oublié donc il ya un
raccourcissement du temps politique et
on moi j'observe là aujourd'hui on est à
30 jours du premier tour le niveau
d'intérêt des français pour cette
élection présidentielle est sensiblement
celui qu'ont observé il ya cinq ans gars
montent à cedar hill et on sait
toutefois alors il ya une vraie question
et je crois que personne n'a vraiment la
réponse est ce que ce conflit en ukraine
cette guerre en ukraine aujourd'hui est
source de remobilisation des français
vis-à-vis d'enjeux débattu or qu'est ce
qu'on remarque à quelques nuances près
l'ensemble des candidats et des
candidates ont une position assez aligné
sur ce que doit être à la fois le rôle
de la france et l union européenne donc
je pense qu'il n'y aura pas beaucoup de
divisions de tension d'opposition sur la
le positionnement de la france vis-à-vis
du conflit ukrainien et est-ce que c'est
forcément favorable à la candidature
d'emmanuel macron dont on se sens que en
temps de crise on ne change pas un
capitaine
dans la tempête oui j'avais peut-être
pour des raisons différentes il ya deux
raisons importantes que je vois qui
donne aujourd'hui un avantage
considérable pour aimer le magro au delà
des intentions de vote où on a vu qu
emmanuel macron maintenant et est proche
et parfois même dépasse 30% d'intentions
de vote au premier tour la première
raison elle est importante parce que
quand on est dans une situation avec
autant d'incertitudes d'inquiétude on le
voit dans les enquêtes l'anxiété est à
son paroxysme en quelque sorte donc dans
ces situations d'un point de vue presque
psychologique la demande des français et
est d'être dans le statu quo une forme
de conservatisme pas idéologique mais
préférons que le président aujourd'hui
en charge de cette crise soit reconduit
parce que il est le seul à démontrer
qu'il a effectivement il là il a réussi
à le démontrer pendant pendant ces trois
semaines la capacité d'être un acteur
alors pour certains pas suffisamment
important pas décisif mais c'est un
acteur qui a pris toute sa place et puis
il ya une deuxième raison
qui a un rapport avec le positionnement
des autres candidats on voit très très
peu d'alternatives
cette guerre est tellement total qu'il
est très compliqué pour des voix
d'opposition d'incarner une alternative
une autre manière de gérer cette guerre
une autre manière pour la france d'avoir
un rôle différent ou d'imposer un autre
thème dans le débat on a parlé un peu
des retraites on va on va en reparler du
pouvoir d'achat dans un instant ça
c'était un sujet mais qui est lié en
fait d'une certaine façon aux
conséquences de guerre en ukraine mais
est ce que là la sourdine de la campagne
est lié effectivement à ce cas ce
contexte international trop fort ou à
des candidats ou des programmes qui
seraient eux trop faible
il est certain que le niveau
d'inquiétude des français vis-à-vis de
la guerre en ukraine il ya une dimension
certes géopolitique une dimension aussi
humanitaire mais il ya une dimension
aussi économique et social et vous avez
raison de deux par les que aujourd'hui
ce qui peut permettre à d'autres thèmes
d'émerger ou de se renforcer pendant la
campagne
sait on en parle depuis des jours
maintenant c'est la question bien sûr de
la facture énergétique
internationale à la fois nationale et
puis très largement le européenne et
d'ailleurs on voit très très très très
mal cette coordination s'organiser au
plan européen les conséquences en terme
de hausse est générale des prix au delà
de au delà de l'énergie et donc il ya
une inquiétude qui dira qui est de dire
finalement depuis cinq ans c'est une
répétition une succession de crises dont
on pense que l'ampleur a été atteinte à
chaque crise et on découvre qu'elle peut
encore être plus profonde avec pour
cette fois ci des conséquences
totalement
impossible d'anticiper dans un avenir de
très court terme et pour revenir à ce
que vous disiez cette crise énergétique
enfin cette hausse des prix de l'énergie
aura bien sûr viendra sans doute à
alimenter gonfler une colère sociale qui
existe déjà et depuis le début du
quinquennat d'emmanuel aqua qui s'est
exprimé sous divers façon est-ce que
vous parliez delà de l'enjeu de la
légitimité du mandat du futur président
si campanile il ya peu où il n'ya pas
avec le risque effectivement de voir ses
préoccupations sociales à nouveau
s'exprimer après la présidentielle est
ce qu'elles font oui alors ça c'est dans
un scénario où effectivement la guerre
en ukraine serait serait interrompue
une négociation pourrait voir le jour et
donc pendant les cinq prochaines années
si tous les débats domestique qui
concerne ce qui relève des
préoccupations au quotidien des français
ne sont pas abordés pendant la campagne
et ne le serai pas pendant la campagne
législative ça va créer un malaise
extrêmement profond entre le corps
social et les représentants politiques
est rappelons le on est dans un pays où
le le rapport aux politiques aux
représentants est extrêmement abîmées
depuis plusieurs années et donc confié
déléguer le pouvoir un président ou une
présidente élue je sens que le j'allais
dire la feuille de route était
totalement débattu confronté on sache
exactement quelle est cette feuille de
route même si le président la république
essaye de faire campagne sur des grands
principes plutôt que des mesures très
précises va rendre ce quinquennat
extrêmement difficile chacun un point de
crispation peut se transformer comme
vous l'avait indiqué en crise sociale et
là je dirais que on a une situation
extrêmement curieuse c'est ça donne le
sentiment que ce dernier qu'un
quinquennat n'a pas permis de dépasser
ce qui a été compris comme les causes
mouvement régie et jaune mais aussi
contestation du politique en gestion de
crise sanitaire et donc il ya une vraie
crainte une double crainte à la fois qui
est totalement un délaissement des
français vis-à-vis de leurs
représentants politiques et ça c'est le
fonctionnement de la démocratie qui est
en danger et puis une deuxième crainte
c'est que on assisterait à une forme de
gérer de cohabitation verticale au plan
national on laisse vraiment les cons en
jeu on ne s'y intéresse pas et au plan
local on se remet à à faire autrement de
la politique je dire autrement c'est à
dire qu'on ne fait pas jouer simplement
la démocratie électorale on entend une
voix seulement quand des élections se
tiennent il ya d'autres formes je pense
de d'incarnation de faire de la
politique au plan local peut être au
delà de la démocratie électorale en un
mot sans faire trop de
prospective c'est un peu compliqué a
priori on voit mal emmanuel macron ne
pas être à ce stade en tout cas au
second tour de la présidentielle est ce
que la seconde place là les jeux sont
très ouverts deuxième place oui je crois
qu'il ya toujours un piège quand on est
donné avec une telle avance c'est vrai
que dans l'histoire de la vème jamais un
candidat à 30 jours de l'élection on
avait une telle avance sur le second le
troisième le quatrième alors pourquoi je
dis le piège c'est parce que on peut se
laisser un petit peu grisés par par une
telle avance pour le second tour oui
c'est ça qui est très curieux parce que
c'est vrai que cette actualité écrase
cette campagne rappelons que nous avons
à peu près un quart de l'électorat
aujourd'hui qui porterait leur voix sur
des candidatures de gauche alors ça
c'est historique ça une importance pour
le second tour quelle va être la
capacité à la fois une mobilisation et
de choix de vote des électeurs de gauche
qui verraient leurs candidats éliminés
dès le premier tour donc pour le second
tour aujourd'hui toutes les enquêtes
montrent que emmanuel macron à une
avance très importante presque 20 points
quel que soit le candidat mais tout cela
est mesurée sans tenir compte de à la
fois comment des électeurs qui verront
leur candidat battu souhaiterait donner
de nouveau un mandat un président
sortant qui est pour l'extrême droite
totalement responsable de tous les
problèmes de la france et puis pour la
gauche ou l'extrême gauche également
responsable de cette crise sociale donc
il ya une vraie inconnue comment vont se
remobiliser et vont-ils se remobiliser
et français vont-ils se remobiliser au
second tour autres conséquences
intéressantes peut-être pour le
politologue que vous êtes des
conséquences de cette crise en ukraine
la force et les candidats à à s'exposer
sur des sujets géopolitique qui disent
en réalité beaucoup de qui ils sont et
de ce en quoi il croit avec des fortunes
à ces diverses pourquoi pensez vous par
exemple que corrigez moi si je me trompe
mais on a le sentiment que marine le pen
pâtit un peu moins qu'eric zemmour de
ses prises de position passées ou
présentes tout cas moi dit clairement
pro poutinienne c'est une c'est une
excellente question parce que on il ya
plusieurs aux thèses qui circulent mais
pour faire très très vite jacques marine
le pen se se démarque se singularise
d'eric zemmour parce que précisément sur
le sujet géopolitique elle est dans une
position qui est un élément parmi
d'autres ayant fait de sa campagne un
sujet sur l'état social du pays la
fracture sociale du pays ce qui n'est
pas le cas d'eric zemmour eric zemmour a
incarné une campagne défendant l'idée
parfois même nostalgique d'une d'une
identité française ce qui l'a amené à
révéler comme disait le général de
gaulle la grandeur de la france et donc
toute sa campagne est articulé autour de
cette haute idée de la france la menant
à prendre des positions géopolitiques
est ce que la france à la candeur encore
la capacité d'être influentes dans le
concert des nations alors ayant cette
campagne ayant choisi ce prisme il a été
effectivement il a dû s'expliquer de ses
positions pro russe et pro poutine ce
qui est moins le cas pour marine le pen
et je dirais une certaine manière
également pour jean luc mélenchon donc
effectivement marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon ont été ont dû s'expliquer sur
leurs positions peut-être assez proche
de l' empire russe en revanche eric
zemmour n'a pas de second thème
domestique et donc il a plus pâti dans
les intentions de vote de cette position
comment est-ce que les développements de
la gare continueront d'influencer sur la
campagne et vice versa on verra ça dans
les semaines qui nous séparent du
premier tour 27 jours maintenant merci
beaucoup ensuite martial foucault est
revenue ce matin ont parlé avec nous sur
le plateau de paris direct directeur du
cevipof